[Musique]
53e édition du salon international de
l'aéronautique et du spatial le
rendez-vous des entreprises spécialisées
dans ces domaines du secteur de la
défense à l'aviation civile bienvenue au
salon du bourget pour un numéro spécial
du 7 8 et co consacrée à l'aéronautique
sur saint quentin en yvelines
tout de suite le sommaire le moteur
hybride ou électrique pour les avions
une technologie en voie de développement
au sein du groupe safran l'équipementier
aéronautique travaillent sur ces
technologies pour tenter de remplacer le
carburant par l'énergie électrique
nous avons rencontré pierre alain
lambert directeur énergie et propulsion
à s'affronter qu'à magny les hameaux les
moteurs de l'a 320 et du boeing 737 max
ou de l'a380 passe par cette usine
le site safran aircraft engines de saint
quentin en yvelines est spécialisée dans
la maintenance et la réparation des
moteurs d'avion découverte de ses
activités auprès des mécaniciens
aéronautique
enfin retour sur le rachat de zodiac
aerospace par safran en 2018
le groupe dont le siège social était
installé à plaisir a connu quelques
changements
rencontre avec le directeur du site
michel ragon
[Musique]
l'hybridation et l'électrification des
avions avec la prise en compte des
problèmes environnementaux c'est l'un
des sujets d'innovation présenté au
salon du bourget 2019 pour en parler
nous sommes sur le stand de
l'équipementier français de
l'aéronautique le groupe safran et nous
sommes avec pierre alain lambert bonjour
bonjour vous êtes directeur pôle énergie
et propulsion sur le site s'affrontaient
cas magny les hameaux alors déjà un mot
sur ce site
est-ce que vous pouvez nous le présenter
alors ça frontex est une entité qui
appartient à la holding du groupe safran
qui est en transverse à toutes les
sociétés du groupe et dont le but est de
faire de la recherche sur des
thématiques d'avenir de long terme ou
sur des thématiques en très fortes
synergies entre les différentes sociétés
différents business du groupe
c'est une entité qui a été créée fin
2013 et qui est de sur le plateau de
saclay depuis son inauguration début
2015 il y a un peu plus de 450 personnes
dans cette entité
et nous travaillons sur toutes les
thématiques de recherche et technologie
du groupe safran dans le domaine de
l'énergétique de des technologies
électriques mais aussi bien évidemment
des matériaux des capteurs et du
numérique qui est un sujet effectivement
aussi très important alors une question
totalement naïve
est ce que demain l'avion aura un moteur
électrique et pourra voler uniquement
avec l'énergie électrique alors l'avion
c'est un vaste monde
il ya des avions des petits et des gros
et tout ce qu'on essaye de faire
justement au sein de cette entité
c'est à travers des compétences qui sont
capables d'appréhender l'avion dans son
intégralité en termes de systèmes
d'énergie et bien arriver à comprendre
quel est l'apport de l'électricité des
technologies électriques sur les
différentes catégories d'aéronefs du
futur les petits comme les gros on peut
pas dire aujourd'hui
l'airbus a320 que vous prenez pour aller
en vacances sera totalement électrique
dans dix ans certainement pas en
revanche pour des véhicules beaucoup
plus petit donc on entend beaucoup
parler
la mobilité à la demande mais aussi des
avions comme hutter aux régionaux de
quelques dizaines de passagers
eh bien les technologies pour être prête
beaucoup plus
sur quoi vous travaillez actuellement à
magny les hameaux et quels outils vous
présenter aujourd'hui que vous
développez notamment l'allemagne et les
tables magny les hameaux est un
mais l'équipe énergie et propulsion
déploie des méthodes et des outils qui
permettent d'appréhender l'avion dans sa
globalité et on se met au service des
sociétés qui vont évaluer l'apport de
leurs propres technologies alors les
technologiques on peut citer évidemment
et qui sont novatrices aujourd'hui dans
ce domaine là c'est la motorisation
électrique
bien évidemment on développe des moteurs
électriques dont on cherche à minimiser
la masse pour les rendre propres à
pouvoir propulsé les avions de taille
significative et puis on développe des
réseaux électriques pour la distribution
de cette énergie propulsive à bord de
ces aéronefs et on travaille aussi sur
la génération d'énergie parce qu'on
pense qu'à part des véhicules de petite
taille
quelques passagers sur une distance de
40 kilomètres des avions tout électrique
c'est à dire uniquement mus par des
batteries ne verront pas le jour avant
très longtemps alors qu'alain lambert il
faut distinguer sur un avion la partie
moteur pour faire fonctionner tout le
système qui à l'intérieur de l'avion il
ya aussi la propulsion ça c'est au
moment du décollage et aussi de
l'atterrissage parce qu'il faut freiner
forcément l'avion là c'est là dessus que
vous travaillez sur les systèmes
électriques et les systèmes
d'hybridation alors on travaille
effectivement sur comment rendre un
moteur plus électriques pour les avions
de transport de passagers
ces technologies là permettent des gains
de carburant mais aussi des gains
d'efficacité en opération des coups de
coude usage par l'électrification et
l'assistance électrique en fait du
moteur classique qui permettent
d'augmenter assez considérablement sa
versatilité sa capacité à être opéré
dans des conditions très différentes
pour les avions plus petits
on travaille sur l'ensemble de la chaîne
propulsive on va parler à ce moment là
deux architectures d'hybridation série
c'est à dire qu'on a une génération
d'énergie quelque part dans l'avion est
ensuite une distribution d'électricité
sur un ensemble de propulseur électrique
et cette génération d'énergie elle se
fait par un mix c'est à dire c'est pour
ça que c'est une hybridation un mixte
entre une batterie et une turbomachines
donc une moteurs à carburants à kérosène
mais qui au lieu d'entraîner directement
une hélice ou un fan va entraîner des
génératrices électriques qui elles vont
générer cette électricité nécessaire à
faire fonctionner les moteurs
électriques les décider demain pour
safran tech magny les hameaux les défis
de demain c'est avant tout de continuer
à travailler sur la performance mais
aussi la fiabilité de ce système là ça
c'est un enjeu très important on
n'introduit pas l'électricité dans
l'aviation pour le plaisir on introduit
bien évidemment parce que c'est beaucoup
plus vertueux son plan environnemental
mais il faut s'assurer absolument que
les systèmes que nous développons reste
au moins aussi fiables que ceux
d'aujourd'hui
ensuite il faut bien comprendre
l'écosystème du transport aérien général
dans lesquelles ces futurs aéronefs vont
être amenés à fonctionner parce que
c'est l'ensemble finalement de la chaîne
d'énergie non seulement l'aéronef
lui-même et la manière dont il dépense
son énergie pendant sa mission mais
également comment cette électricité est
fabriqué est produite qu'il faut prendre
en compte
et puis on travaille aussi sur les
carburants futur les carburants plus
vers les carburants moins émissifs de
co2 pour bien comprendre les filières
bien comprendre la manière dont on les
certifie pour l'aviation
et c'est l'ensemble de cet écosystème
qui va nous permettre d'avoir une vision
complète du futur de la propulsion car
alain lambert merci beaucoup et on va
prendre la direction d'un autre site
implanté à magny les hameaux safran
aircraft engines et inauguré en 1990
cette usine est dédié à la maintenance
des moteurs des avions civils
restauration réparation et inspection
découverte des activités de cette usine
ce reportage
un moteur d'un airbus a320 sur le poste
de travail de josé et thibault ces deux
techniciens aéronautique du site safran
aircraft engines de magny les hameaux
font un contrôle une inspection à
l'intérieur de la turbine du moteur
grâce à un endoscope et à voir
une nouvelle température au niveau
les blagues de la turbine mais
apparemment elle est propre
le contrôle se poursuit aussi sur les
différentes parties du moteur donc ici à
l'avant nous avons la partie soufflante
la partie soufflante ces ventilateurs en
fait c'est lui qui va aspirer l'air pour
envoyer à l'intérieur du compresseur en
fait qui est composé de la chambre de
combustion et du compresseur
donc c'est là que l'air va être comprimé
dans cette partie là
donc ce sont des plusieurs étages des
lettres qui vont se réduire et comprimer
l'air et qui vont l'amener dans la
chambre de combustion ici nous avons ici
donc la dernière partie est en fait
c'est cette partie là qui va entraîner
donc les blade à l'avant et qui va faire
que le moteur va faire décoller l'avion
c'est ce qui va donner la puissance
démontage et remontage des moteurs
d'avion réparation nettoyage ou contrôle
de certaines pièces
le quotidien des 700 salariés de cette
usine implantée à saint quentin en
yvelines depuis 1990 pour démonter un
moteur à partir du moment où ils
arrivent chez nous jusqu'à la pièce
unitaire il faut compter une semaine une
grosse semaine
ensuite vous avez les opérations de
lavage donc ça c'est trois jours le
contrôle une quinzaine de jours puis
leur montage qui fait qu'un moteur est
chez nous un peu plus de deux mois
airbus a380 boeing 737 max airbus a320
neo ou encore boeing 777
ce site soit près de 15 moteur par mois
directement en provenance des compagnies
aériennes on est plutôt en croissance
d'activité le trafic aérien est en
croissance importante et bien
nous embauchons en moyenne une
cinquantaine de personnes chaque année
principalement des montres aéronautique
des contrôleurs aéronautique des
techniciens l'adaptation aux nouveaux
systèmes installés sur les moteurs
nouvelle génération le défi de demain
pour le site safran aircraft engines de
magny les hameaux
c'est officiel depuis 2018 s'apprend à
racheter zodiac aerospace pour former
trois entités safran cabine sa francité
safran aerosystem pour le groupe zodiac
dont le siège était implantée à plaisir
plusieurs changements sont intervenus
nous avons rencontré le directeur de
l'établissement le directeur du site
safran de plaisir c'est michel taguant
bonjour bonjour nicolas
alors voilà plus d'un an que safran à
racheter zodiac aerospace je rappelle
que le siège social de zodiac aerospace
et est implantée ici à plaisir qu'est ce
qui a changé depuis plus d'un an
oui après la prise de contrôle par le
groupe safran zodiac aerospace en
décembre 2018 a fusionné dans safran
était organisée en trois sociétés
safran aerosystem safran cabine et
safran site ces trois sociétés sont
basées ici sur le site de plaisir et
safran aerosystem qui est la plus
importante d'entre elles avec un prêt de
40 80 % des effectifs 2500 personnes à
son siège social
ici sur le site de plaisir n'a eu dé
restructuration au niveau des bureaux
des activités de suivre les quelques
réaménagements au niveau des bureaux
réorganisation des activités pour chacun
trouve sa place
et puis on l'a vu un devant le site
changement de panneaux aussi le logo le
nouveau logo tout à fait oui on conserve
quand même quelques apparitions dans
l'est dans les bureaux dont sur le site
de zodiac aerospace et on veut conserver
quand même cette image
or il ya quand même une trace historique
que vous avez pu voir dans l'entré
puisque donc un siècle un peu plus d'un
siècle d'histoire de vie avec les rospez
ne s'efface pas comme ça donc on a
conservé les plaques de bronze à
l'entrée alors vous l'avez dit le groupe
l'intégration du groupe zodiac aerospace
a permis de former trois entités safran
cabine safran site et safran aerosystem
qu'est ce que vous faites concrètement
ici à plaisir alors sur le site de
plaisir notre activité qui sont
principalement liées au système de
gestion de carburant avec des jauges de
carburant au système de gestion du
givrage et du dégivrage sur les aéronefs
au système oxygène avec des masques de
pilotes des masques de passagers et des
systèmes de calculateurs embarqués
système de vidéosurveillance sur les 09
ou quel métier on retrouve sur ce site
on va trouver des métiers de type
conception donc ingénieurs techniciens
en termes d'électronique en termes de
mécanique beaucoup de métier de
logistique aussi
les métiers commerciaux techniciens
support après-vente programme management
de programme
michel takam dernière question sur les
défis de demain
alors les défis de demain c'est d'abord
l'avion plus vert plus respectueux de
l'environnement
consommant moins de carburant c'est
aussi l'avion plus sûr pour lequel
safran hero system est bien placé en
étant le leader mondial de la sécurité
aéronautique et pour ça et bien
effectivement nous renforçons nos
équipes nous avons un plan de
recrutement de plus de 100 personnes par
an dans des métiers de techniciens et
d'ingénieurs électronique mécanique de
logistique de service après vente de
support technique aussi des recrutements
prévus dès cette année ou l'année
prochaine sont déjà en cours
déjà à l'oeuvre depuis l'année qui vient
de s'écouler elle continue pour l'année
qui va venir un site internet pour
postuler safran hero system coin comme
michel d'ailleurs merci beaucoup de nous
avoir reçus sur le site safran de
plaisir merci nicolas
[Musique]
et c'est à côté du rafale produit par
l'entreprise dassault aviation que nous
allons conclure cette émission le rafale
c'est un succès mondial plusieurs
exportations mais c'est surtout le
fleuron de l'armée française merci de
nous avoir suivis dans ce set 8 échos
spéciale au salon du bourget à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]